Okay, and the answer is Apache/22.3.
Now, if you put in
Big IP,
we accepted that, but I'm pretty sure you didn't use urlib2.
Because when I was finding the answer to this,
I also cheated, used curl, and got Big IP,
which is actually what www.example.com uses,
but urllib2 automatically follows redirects,
and the server it redirects to uses Apache.
So let me show you how I got the example,
and then we'll go ahead and talk about what happened with the redirect.
Okay, so the way I found this answer is
I used urllib2.
I used the url open function to hit www.example.com.
I stored that in a variable,
and then I looked at its headers.
I see that the server is Apache/22.3.
And that's the correct answer.
If we look at the url attribute on P,
we see it's actually iana.org.
Now, if you remember from Unit 1, I asked you what is the location header
when you hit www.example.com.
And that was because--
And this was the answer, because example.com redirects to iana.org.
Now, urllib2 automatically follows redirects,
which can sometimes be confusing.
And in this case, it automatically followed the redirect.
It hit iana.org, whose server is Apache.
But we're going to do this by hand. I'm going to use curl.
This is the Unit 1 example.
We can see that server is actually Big IP.
So hopefully you used urllib2, but if you cheated like I did
when I was writing this quiz and you saw Big IP, we'll also accept that.
And it's important to know, when you're using these libraries,
that a lot of these libraries--urllib2,
the default one included in Google App Engine called URL Fetch--
they follow redirects automatically.
And if you don't want to follow the redirects,
say your are writing a grading script for your homeworks,
you need to look up the docs.
There's almost always an option to tell the library not to follow automatically follow redirects.
So that's something to keep in mind when you get behavior you don't expect
as just happened to me.
Okay, let's move on.